it's time to babble the [ __ ] on
[Music]
this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
Wow it is Saturday night in Sin City so
let's babble the [ __ ] on I'm the fat one
Kevin Smith and I'm the drunk and broke
one Ralph Garman oh my good lord so
excellent to see you people we're happy
his [ __ ] clam sold the [ __ ] out give
yourselves a nice round thank you what a
[ __ ] day I had sir I did I was at the
Hard Rock Hotel and I looked out my
window a sea of half-naked kids as far
as you could see just 20-somethings like
fist [ __ ] pumping wearing next to no
clothes felt like I was back in Jersey I
bet it's pretty awesome
what Snooki down there you know they
looked up at me in the window though
like it's the guy Snooki its snook oh
they're in town I think I think Snooki's
in town doing an event here this week
Pauly D's all he's the in residence here
as a DJ he has tenure I believe they're
making so much more money than us I know
we shouldn't even make fun of them
they're making fun of us yeah really
like keep laughing at us [ __ ] oh that
one dude be like I'll pay you $10,000 to
suck my dick I'm like okay you're so
cheap I know at least haggle when you
try to negotiate all right I'm like 10
gram but no camera phones yeah yeah yeah
it's ridiculous the only thing we can
look forward to is their eventual
descent into a heroin addiction and
toothless Ness that doesn't happen
everyone from New Jersey I still got
online I'm talk about the Jersey raw can
I get a straw for my drink can we get
Kevin a straw I mean we're in Vegas were
sold out can I get a straw
welcome ladies and gentlemen to
Hollywood babble-on it is my pleasure
Ralph's pleasure to sit here and make
fun of our betters for you all for
tonight long
absolutely but as always we begin the
show with shout outs to lovely people
who are in the room yes sir and it all
starts like this
it's shout out Kevin at Brown so get
your [ __ ] out
[Music]
get your cocktail hour
[Applause]
I forgot sorry yeah I have another job
tonight I'm also DJ I don't normally do
this James that the club does it but
today I'm being taxed I have to try to
be funny and I have to work the sound Q
I know I have to do two things this is I
haven't been this tech since [ __ ]
quick stuff yeah here we go okay
our Trish and Shane in the audience
tonight nobody is more here than Trish
I'll tell you that much welcome here
she's like yes right in the front row
here's the Trish's shout out email so
excited you guys are coming to Vegas I
bought tickets as soon as I heard but a
longtime fan and listen on stitcher
every week yeah you can hear us on
stitcher comm stitcher butcher bringing
my son who likes you guys but doesn't
listen as much [ __ ] that's your mother
do you know how many [ __ ] but [ __ ]
jokes we're gonna do tonight
you guys wanna put a chair between you
as always this is gonna get weird
alright because as long as you guys are
cool that kind of I had no idea we were
such a family show last night we had all
kinds of families and stuff I know yeah
it's America's playground that's right
there were kids in the show last night
could you please give me a my son Shane
a shout-out in my favorite you're Sean
Connery boys Thank You Trish well look
at you two mother and son
sharing [ __ ] and ass jokes what a close
family you must be and by close I made
incestuous you twisted [ __ ] that's
another way of saying well welcome yeah
welcome that's awesome man mom and son
hanging out going to the show and [ __ ] I
wish my mother would come to the show
with me
sit right here you me and my no that's
not what I wanted all be awesome and
like everyone saw why you'd go to curse
and my mother would be like Ralph you're
better than that yeah and then I first I
would go curse and then she'd be like
well done tiger because that [ __ ] knows
curse and makes money
how about Andrew and Tricia you guys in
the crowd tonight Andrew and Tricia hey
there hello where are you right over
here that was non-committal what are you
afraid of getting shot or something like
that you're like we can't give away our
position get it loud man where are you
right here
alright on no I want to hear him it was
very non-committal they were like Andrew
writes I know you're probably tired of
people pleading with you to convince
their girlfriends to do anal so I won't
ask I brought my girlfriend Trish with
me tonight she already loves anal so
there's no convincing necessary that's
why she didn't yell loud before yeah
she's like a [ __ ] Duggar I have no
boys cuz I'm always like she's not
sitting comfortable yeah no Andrew heads
that's all honestly I'm just telling
everyone I mean seriously look at her
now look at me I look like Kevin's
chunky cousin and she's damn and again
anal yes that's him you stand up anal
girl let's see you take a penis in you
straighter you're adventurous
uncomfortable well one of you is you're
able to relax parts of your body that
instinctually tighten up you fart loudly
wood and wetly sometimes
just goes the reason crank and romana
Gregan seriously that was idiot nothing
else if not littered he was just
bragging about the fact this anal sex
all the time
mad respect man you wrote the letter
just to brag you know done Craig and
Romana where were you right right here
once again yeah he said sorry would he
get you soon enough sir we're trying to
move along my birthday was last week and
my wife bought me tickets to your show
in Vegas we're driving in from Phoenix
to celebrate with you guys you come in
from Phoenix oh well thanks [ __ ]
Alice from Mel's Diner early to bed
early to rise and in between I cooked
and clean I went out of my head going
through life with blinders on is tough
to see I had to get out get up from
under and look for me there's a new girl
in town and she is looking good there's
a fresh freckled face in the
neighborhood there's I gotta stop
[Applause]
but we're in Vegas you do that kind of
thing in Vegas tell your friends you
were there the night Kevin became a
lounge singer next up I'll be doing my
pasties routine as well
[Applause]
Craig Wright's driving in from Phoenix
you may remember me as the creator of
Babel recall and Babel trick the search
for [ __ ] an awesome all right work area
great work very sir with your work quite
a stand up that gentleman did some very
funny stuff for us over the past couple
weeks to mother better filmmaker than I
am I'll say - very funny videos he sent
us over the past couple weeks we
appreciate it
he said I'm sure as Kevin probably said
to all the theaters that showed cop out
thanks for showing my work even though
no one laughed like I said you're not
nearly as good as me
thanks Craig and Ramona Alicia and Chris
Fiat Ciccone fiyaquun' a how do you say
your last name be a cone here cone hey
meatballs
that's your tell yeah well they like
meatballs Oh big fan and listening since
the beginning along with most of the
other SModcast shows well we think you
didn't have to travel very far tonight
since we're locals and live about five
miles away you lazy lazy [ __ ] but we
both originate from the east coast and
my husband's family started out in New
Jersey if that helps it does help we're
in the East Coast story from New York
and Jersey Massachusetts get out get out
East Coast my ass he's an HBO virgin and
a big comic book fan I would love it if
you'd welcome to the show as Adam West
Thank You Alicia and Chris well
welcome old chum to Hollywood babble-on
quickly have anal sex with that woman
she probably doesn't let just anybody do
it though right no I don't remember that
line from Batman oh yeah I was there's
one of the Lois the lilac episodes that
Ralph and Kevin I want to thank you for
coming to Vegas me my buddy Dave we're
planning a trip to LA for HBO this
August but lo and behold here you are
this is from Marcos Marcos and Davy you
guys here there you go hey guys make
some noise you may remember me as the
guy who wanted had the Superman theme
played at his wedding I do remember when
you wrote us in asking about that and I
said I drove to my wedding in the
Batmobile he's the least that could
happen for this dude is it for his wife
to let him play the Superman theme when
he walked down the aisle my wife did not
let me play the Superman theme as I walk
down the aisle [ __ ] be like that man
so I'd like you to give a shout out to
me Marco's Dave Stu and his fiancee
Dorothy and his brother Matt and not my
wife
[ __ ] her she's not here
no Superman for me no HBO for her sounds
a lot more like her loss than my effects
again for coming to Vegas and then
Marcos has Ken cape Kevin please bring
red-state to Vegas yeah yeah this is we
had two nights we played last night and
we played tonight and sold out both
nights so I feel like we can easily sell
out at least two screaming a big story
so we'll be back we'll be back in about
a month with a screening of red states
look for that will hopefully be back
here every month if you guys are into it
yeah would that be cool although I don't
know if I can afford it were you
gambling too Tom
[ __ ] me I was it was Clark Griswold
today that's who I was sitting the black
Jack Taylor you out in the alley and
kick you in the balls and take all your
money that's what was happening to me
literally just what couldn't win a
[ __ ] hand all afternoon I just got
spanked
you gotta learn how to gamble dude my
account of gambling is here I'm like do
I get the strawberry shake or the
chocolate shake
I'll get the strawberry you know what
I'll get both it's Vegas so when the
Vegas stays in my [ __ ] stomach yeah
but I'm gonna make all my money back
tonight though after the show oh yeah
yeah you'll get it you'll get them
that's a night your night it works let's
listen to some emails from all over the
world shall we of course
[Music]
got an email featuring Kevin's reactions
this comes from Laura Ford either Apple
a 35 year old housewife from Iowa of all
places I was thinking now that Kevin has
a whole suite before we jump into these
people aren't here no sir there's
somebody we didn't hit him in the
shoutouts and I don't think we have to
eat the email or the letter but I saw it
on Twitter is somebody's birthday today
a dude who's 40
what's your name [ __ ] his name
is the monsters of Young Frankenstein
happy birthday to one person yell it
very Claire
[Music]
Gary Gary Jerrod Eric what a mistake
this was Jesus Christ those trying to be
nice and other matters like Barry you
[ __ ] Steve John bill Patrick a lumpy
birthday dude welcome and happy 40th
birthday whoever you want birthday to
you I heard Chewie
hold on do that Chewie guy hold on right
wait wait go quiet go quiet hold on a
count of three count of three count of
three listen I'm a director [ __ ] here
we go one two three go it sounded better
the first time this next email comes
from Logan dry Dale in Regina he adds
the city that rhymes with fun Regina I'm
having it ongoing in their license plate
I believe it is it'd be amazing I'm
gonna move there just to make a ton of
Regina jokes I'm having an ongoing
argument with my neighbor over weeds not
the good kind Kevin growing over three
feet tall and a fence that is two inches
over my property line I wanted to show
my disgust for him so I'm now using the
US military's version of torture by
turning up my outdoor deck speakers as
loud as I can when we go to when I see
him go outside what better song to put
on a continuous loop I thought as loud
as possible then an hey she's butthole
you guys have done so much for me
already and I appreciate it but could
you please tell my neighbor Farooq to
[ __ ] off
absolutely [ __ ] you farouq farouq farouq
farouq is on fire we don't need them
water let the [ __ ] burn this
email is from John steezy Andrew and
poncho
you guys here too this is a combo email
shouted I even realized you guys were
gonna be here it's a combo just get your
[ __ ] out today is Steve's birthday oh
happy birthday cz stes II Oh [ __ ]
excuse me but I don't know the right way
to pronounce tezi like that's a name
[ __ ] people all right steady
[ __ ] what made you think steezy
what did make you think it's easy
there's only one E well I don't know how
steady is usually via spelled I
apologize generally speaking it would be
the double e or ei to pronounced easy
this is clearly says E
[Applause]
desi and drew and Pancho are here from
Orange County California by today is
stes e's birthday tomorrow is ponchos
and dopey and sleepy and Doc wanted
their birthdays since we represent mi a
Rocky Horror shadow cast from Orange
County I'm not familiar with the shadow
cast or not but those are guys who get
up on stage while the movie is playing
and will act out the movie while the
movie plays behind them as opposed to
just interacting with Rocky Horror you
actually get up on stage and costume and
stuff and you not got the musical number
like if you ever saw that movie Fame the
first one I don't know if they did it in
the second one at one point they get up
there's a bunch of people that perform
the movie while it's happened right it's
very entertaining it would be great if
you could sing a little sweet
transvestite from Rocky Horror as Edie
win thanks for the laughs John slash
Jesus he calls himself hey soos sure is
full of your insight for none hey Zeus
or Jay Zeus it's Jesus yeah [ __ ] you
[Applause]
well sure why not absolutely how do you
do I see you've met my faithful handyman
he's just a little brought down because
when you're not he thought you were the
Candyman don't you know don't get strung
out by the way I look don't judge a book
by it's cover I'm not much of a man by
the light of day but by night I'm one
hell of a lover I'm a three transvestite
don't you know from transsexual
Transylvania life's for the living thank
you
the more that a shadow cast that's
something we could totally use like so
in the midst of our show we have
somebody up here doing a show in front
of our show leg and [ __ ] and every once
in a while we're like a toast to
Hollywood they throw top status who [ __ ]
like that new releases this weekend as
we look at the headlines the help is in
theaters everywhere this stars Emma
Stone and Bryce Dallas Howard I would I
would just spank myself silly watching
this movie wouldn't there it's about two
folks not two folks it's about one girl
who comes back home after college and
she decides to write a book about the
african-american maids in her
neighborhood
okay takes place in the 60s right on
Glee the 3d concert movie opens this
weekend it did not open that well Ralph
it opened last night and it did I think
it was like three or four million or
something well if you can watch these
kids sing and dance every week on
television why would you pay money to go
see it exactly they said it opened a
little bit lower or about the same place
as the Jonas Brothers concert movie
which did not open very well at all
however in 3d can you imagine Liam
Michele's nose coming at you when you
live theater that would be horrific oh
[ __ ] all I want to see coming at me and
3d Glee is the gay kid man
that would be hard I love about the
concert that the kid who's in the
wheelchair on the show has to perform in
the wheelchair come on let me do some
tap I [ __ ] walk come on 30 minutes or
less opens this weekend Jesse Eisenberg
Aziz Ansari Danny McBride in a very
funny comedy and final destination five
about people who cheat death again and
again and again and again is doing a
[ __ ] job these kids are still [ __ ]
around man yeah
Jane Elaine's like hey what the [ __ ]
about me where was Akamai three it
opened at number three Ralph in position
in the box office chair Planet of the
Apes was number one again yesterday did
you see it yeah I still haven't seen I
really want to go but my kid
and I saw my kids and she was away for
about a week and stuff and I was like
what did you do while you were gone she
was like Baba bah and it was like real
cool [ __ ] she's like I've rode horses
and I did a skeet shooting I did this I
was like I heard you saw a movie and she
was like yeah I was like which one she's
like planet oh how awesome was that she
was like well I mean it was good I guess
and I was like what do you mean she's
like well she went with her friend and
they were sitting there watching the
movie and I guess in the first like 10
minutes 15 minutes something happens
with a neighbor neighbor calls in
something bad is that right and my kid
goes like if the neighbor hadn't called
that in the Planet of the Apes would
never happen and she was Liza and she
goes kill the neighbor is that that's my
girl
no where lines ever gonna [ __ ] with you
you don't encourage that kind of
behavior at that age [ __ ] yes killing
the neighbors really if they get in the
way not if they get in the way but if
they're gonna be responsible for the
rise of the Planet of the Apes yes kill
the neighbors I feel bad I think we're
responsible for something even worse
than the Rise of the Planet of the Apes
well last night's show we were here and
inadvertently out of nowhere I did an
Austin Powers impression good segue
which no one has done in
because I mean I know it's a bad Segway
when I pointed out but it was so smooth
I was just I admired my partner's Segway
was so and I'd literally I did that and
it broke the segue and now it's a bad
segue I'm so you'll find if you drop
your pants and [ __ ] on the segue it's
not quite it's not quite as effective I
know I wouldn't have I'm too stoned to
remember to tell you later on that was a
great segue so I felt like I wanted to
tell you right now just make a note okay
wanna be like memento writing notes all
over myself last night I did hours
impression purely by accident it came
out of nowhere and today was announced
Mike Meyers signed a deal for Austin
Powers for really that's a good thing
I'm a little worried
I think it's essentially enough time has
gone by where I think you could probably
do it again without people being like
you [ __ ] jerk like they'll be happy
to see Austin Goldmember the last one
2002 so it has been 19 years by the time
they're done it'll be like a decade
since the last one yeah
he is signed on no word on who's gonna
direct yet they're hoping Jay Roach will
bring it back but every hay goes to the
Gehring swinger baby yeah put that away
now I gotta get back into town oh don't
encourage that kind of thing it was just
we just got over [ __ ] 10 years of
people being like okay hi I'll make you
holy bait not with that voice though
there you are stop it [ __ ] relic
that's Robin shagadelic man really
behave you creeped me out
do your [ __ ] show to the show stop it
creepy [ __ ] more shocking movie news
today dr. Disney announced they are
shutting down production on their
multi-million dollar big-budget epic
they had planned The Lone Ranger with
Johnny Depp Johnny Depp was going to
play Tonto an army hammer from the
Facebook movie yes who played the twins
he was gonna play The Lone Ranger but
the budget this is the reason for the
but of the shutdown the budget had
climbed to 232 million dollars it's a
Western it just makes me go 232 million
dollars for a movie about Tonto how or
how that is [ __ ] madness dude but you
know what your foes and arrows can you
buy 232 minutes this story if you know
the story of The Lone Ranger - it's like
like he's a guy who was wounded left for
dead the Indian fires I'm Tonto he puts
him back together and he becomes his
best buddy and then wears the mask he's
supposed to be a dead man blah blah blah
right does that's not 200 and unless you
add [ __ ] like and then Dragons pop
out of the earth there's not a 232
million dollar budget I just don't
understand I mean I know he gets paid a
lot and pay him handsomely he's the
reason everyone's gonna go see the movie
that's not all salary that it's just
that's a that's a huge [ __ ] figure
and it's a weird issue because you go
like okay
Disney is showing responsibility and
going like that's just too much we can't
[ __ ] do it because it's not just this
figure all the players the participants
which is like Jerry Bruckheimer Johnny
Depp Gore Verbinski all these guys get a
huge piece of the back end so even if
they make the movie like two hundred
thirty two million means this has to
make this Western has to make five
hundred million dollars worldwide for
them to see a penny of profit so they
finally just stopped and they were like
look it's [ __ ] madness we can't do it
but the problem here is you could
alienate your biggest [ __ ] star se
the Pirates movies have may have made
billions of dollars for Disney you know
I think they sort of owe them this one
you know but that's not at that I don't
know it's weird like you wonder one of
two things is at work here behind the
story one is
he's gonna Johnny Depp's gonna be all
sorts of ticked and suddenly Disney's
not gonna be his home anymore his
connect was dick cook who used to run
the studio and he's gone there are new
guys there so the teeth of that or maybe
just Johnny Depp was like look if it
went away I wouldn't care I got a
zillion other things to do or something
or he wanted to play Tonto as gay in
drunk that's what I'm thinking that
would have been hilarious Sammi that's
hi-ho silver away no maybe they were
concerned about the performance in there
I doubt it he's just that dude is like
an ATM he's just like printing money so
for them to shut that movie down it has
to be I think also the third thing it's
probably them reacting to Cowboys and
Ally
that's what I was thinking Cowboys and
Aliens came out and it didn't [ __ ]
like die a miserable death but it ain't
doing very well looks like it's gonna
crawl to a hundred million and it was a
one hundred and sixty million dollar
quasi space Western mashup so sounds
like these cats over Disney were just
like well [ __ ] that movie doesn't
work our movie could never work cause
it's the same movie even though it's not
nothing nothing so you know but how
about just get your house in order and
figure out a way to make that [ __ ]
movie for like no more than 100 million
bucks I mean the Coen Brothers went in
made a Western and they made it for like
30 60 something like that I don't know
what a True Grit cost but it wasn't it
didn't even come close to a [ __ ]
hundred it made a lot of money yeah and
they made a bunch of money so I know
it's just crazy man those budgets are
getting way out of control and then I
read a story I'm sorry this shit's not
funny but it's sad at the same time I
read a story and I forget one of the
trades either a reporter or a variety
where it wasn't one of the bold-faced
names in the Disney Company in the story
that we just read but it was somebody at
Disney who's worked in there event
programming or something and they said
their whole manifest right now at Disney
is to just make event pictures the dude
literally said he pointed out here
they're the studio's own Alice in
Wonderland and he goes look it was a
visual spectacle in an event picture the
story was bad the audience didn't care
they know they're making crap they don't
give a [ __ ] anymore they just want your
[ __ ] money and it's so sad that's
what Walt Disney had in mind I think
when he started the studio
[ __ ] the kids give me your money used to
be over Cinderella's castle I think when
you went into the park
it's just sickening to a guy like me
because they just they're getting rid of
all the mid-level budget movies and god
forbid the lower budgets that got rid of
Miramax altogether so they're not in the
business of making arthouse films at all
they just want to make massive [ __ ]
flicks they just want to make like Alice
in Wonderland in 3d or they got this
[ __ ] John Carter of Mars movie coming
out but like there's who's the dude in
it do you know who the dude who's
playing John Carter is no he's one of
the guys from Friday Night Lights I
don't know it's may god only the ride
movies coming out they have a haunted
mansion coming out with Delta didn't
they just say they're gonna make like a
Wizard of Oz with James Franco or
something like that
yeah there's some sort of like Wizard of
Oz ish kind of like an Alice in
Wonderland II and kind of movie they did
where it's connected all the Disney is
spinning in his freezer right now that's
not telling you it's weird man it's it's
it's just so much money too and they
just don't get it it all comes down to
the [ __ ] story it's like dude if the
story captures the audience they don't
give a [ __ ] what it looks like if they
touch the mirror makes them laugh make
something they'll [ __ ] pay but these
cats all they think is like you just
have to pour money at it it's got a good
story give them a good story
give them cop-out no don't give them
come no no no just give them a good
story that's what they want while we're
talking about people with a lot of money
making more Tyler Perry's getting his
own TV network
hallelujah very good
hallelujah [ __ ] Madea [ __ ] I don't
know I I'm gonna go the other way I like
this black person I'd be so offended but
you yes he built his [ __ ] from scratch
though his whole empire this - nobody
ever believes in this dude he started
writing Oprah believed in him eventually
but be Oprah didn't hear about him until
he made his name on the circuit like
taking shows out mounting productions
selling out houses and they don't pay
attention to you until you start making
money and that's what my start paid
attention to but even when he started
making money for studios like he went
into TBS he's got some show I don't
watch it but the Royal paid over
southern Africa house of Payne House of
Payne he went in there and he said
here's the here's the script so here's a
budget this is what I'd like to do and
they're like wow will shoot one test it
see how it goes we're not sure if it's
for us he's like you know what never
mind went back to his own [ __ ] worried I
guess he's in Georgia Atlanta Atlanta he
shot a full-season
cut himself tested them vetted the
entire thing brought it back to TBS and
then sold it to him for like twice what
they would have had it if they'd just
done it themselves so the dudes like
he's got the indie spirit the fact that
he's finally to a point where he's like
I'm gonna try a TV channel he could
actually pull it off he's gonna be
reruns of House of Pain meet the Browns
and all the Madea movies and then he's
gonna add more prod more more
programming later sighs I mean I doubt
I'll ever watch it but I respect what
he's doing he's built it is great he's
put all of his work in one place so I
can ignore him all it was it's nice I
don't I don't have to do it I thought
the bob and weave anymore I can just
block that channel and I am free
hallelujah I'm free nobody knows the
trouble Tyler Perry calls me Kanye West
in a completely unrelated story is being
stalked what not a big story except when
you find out who he's being stalked by
he's being stalked by - Chelsea
Handler's guy said
oh one scud missile itself Maul my
problems at once in that case
2010's Miss Universe Albania is his
stalker that's that's class that's style
when your stalker is a former contestant
in the Miss Universe pageant that rules
she's stalking him yes oh she's just
like I love you so much more than that
she's trying to bust into his party show
up at his house go to restaurants where
he is and she's telling all of his inner
circle that they're very much in love
even though they've never met it's right
to use his vonage yes she's crazy for a
Kanye West she keeps showing that she's
cuckoo for Kanye I need that I need a
stalker
I am your stalk I know but you're not
Miss Universe Albania like Miss Universe
Albania he's in the eye of the beholder
I've got bigger boobs than Miss Albania
though Michael Jackson he's having a
another well he's not having anything
they're having another concert in his
honor a memoriam if you will yeah in
Wales to celebrate his life and legacy
called Michael forever so that's where
he was from well no he was from Gary
Indiana so what is the Welsh iMac I
haven't quite figured it out yet
but it's happening in Cardiff Wales
Michael forever the tribute concert only
half the family is behind it the other
half doesn't want it to go on so there's
some schism between the family regarding
this concert they're putting it on as a
memorial and they also had a problem
because they haven't said who's playing
there today they finally announced the
lineup for the concert okay it our
studded no it is alien ant farm
what are they sing they were at an all
trock group that did a cover of smooth
criminal his song had a big hit with
that it was like karaoke version yeah
Leona Lewis who was popular for a minute
with that bleedin love song she was from
the x-factor over in the UK no Cee Lo
Green and Christina Aguilera
okay how the Wales thing makes sense to
me it's Christina Aguilera and see have
you seen her lately
no she big oh yeah oh yeah how many
seats does she have to buy on an
airplane October 8th is the date so if
you want to buy your tickets and get the
whales
you've only got months and months and
there will be plenty of seats when you
get there
did any of those people ever meet
Michael Jackson I believe Christina did
did she
yeah and CeeLo may have to I don't know
who else is a [ __ ] Katherine Heigl get
out of here yeah I don't believe that
for a second she was on Grey's Anatomy
of course she left because her movie
career was blowing up yeah and I
remember she had some friction there she
was getting into rows and wheelbarrows
if you will she went to see the Broadway
show the Book of Mormon which is the one
that was done by Trey and Matt the guys
do South Park yeah showed up late and
when she got there she was supposed to
wait until the act break she insisted on
going in so they let her go in and then
she had to have everyone stand up on her
row so she could get to her seat that
she pulls out one of those isa Koretz
electronic cigarettes with the water
vapor never sees just to work during the
whole show blowing the water vapor
everywhere pissing off everyone else
around her yeah they said she was she
was really cranky and no one enjoys her
a tracing leading up she was raised as a
Mormon not funny but interest
interesting uh uh you can't just smoke
those e-cigarettes everywhere and you
can you can but you can't like what
people that do it do it kind of
antagonistically like news Jason Mewes
got caught on a flight smoke and we
talked about on the podcast once and he
upsets some woman some woman was just
like he's smoking they called the
stewardess and [ __ ] people the
stewardess overnight flight attendant he
can't say stewardess flight attendant
came back said what's going on they saw
smoke and they were like it's not coming
from the wing and [ __ ] like they
alerted the captain and then Alstom
where we landed to like ladies and
gentleman please remain in your seats we
just have to deboard one passenger first
and I'm sitting apart from him and I was
like please don't be mused please don't
be news and sure enough I look back and
there he's like guru awful me taking him
off the [ __ ] plane when I got off the
plane he told me this story like they
had to let him go there's no law against
right but I'm like dude as where I said
what the [ __ ] happens I go was sleeping
and I said yeah he's like then I heard
the ding and I was like what thing is
that cuz we were landing I was like okay
and so then what he's like well because
we're allowed what started smoking I was
like dude you don't start doing anything
outside the norm as the plane is coming
down that's when everybody gets [ __ ]
antsy and [ __ ] and there was an older
woman who signaled Matt pointed him out
and got uptight about it so we're
leaving the terminal the cops have
cleared him and [ __ ] like that and he's
like hold on hold on one second I said
why he's gonna see that old lady and I
said why is that cuz I'm gonna tell her
she's a [ __ ] idiot and I was a kid
outside man don't [ __ ] harass the
elderly and [ __ ] can't understand your
computer cigarette while we're talking
about theater there would be gravy it
was on that plane looking out in the
Kremlin out there smoking away in an
e-cigarette it would change the whole
story I've been very different while
we're talking about theater you can't
[ __ ] do Shatner and not do Shatner
you brought it up dude
there's a gremlin on the plane smoking
water vapor gone I don't know why he's
calling for Connie just does why we're
talking about theater the oscar-winning
movie The King's Speech is meeting being
made into a play they're gonna do it on
stage I can see that it's pretty
dialogue heavy and beloved and whatnot
they're not gonna add songs I hope it's
a musical that'd be awesome I am The
King nothing
Len a long long musical now then he just
has to say [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
the big show stop number Selita Ebanks
the Victoria's Secret model hmm she also
this week came out and said that her
ex-husband Nick Cannon had a small piece
oh he's do that married right there yeah
why do I have to know how big everyone's
dick is why can't women stop saying this
stuff yeah good point especially if your
name's Nick Cannon how disappointing is
that yeah really
change your name to Nick derringer what
are you gonna do what are your choices
Nick peashooter yeah I'll save everyone
the trouble I have a really small dick
well then see that is your prerogative
you can say that about yourself if you
want I have a huge [ __ ] but I don't
around talking about it so I think it's
up to each man to say whether whatever
he wants to say about his penis but no
one else should have that conversation
even though again mine is huge I don't
choose to bring it up in mixed company
fair enough
did I mention my low-hanging balls if
I'd like this much much bigger you're
nuts party girl Mike far as you know yes
low-hanging balls
I do have low hangars what do you call
Junkers yeah my wife has heard
screeching Anil and I were in a hotel
toilet that's different than our own at
home ah what water's cold
I've hit water your balls go into the
toilet yeah that deeply yeah have you
ever flush Tamila
I was once in an airplane it got sucked
out over Toledo with the blue eyes geek
news as time as we take a look every
week to stuff that's kevin and i live
and die for Kevin Kevin Rockingham Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows part-2
congratulations to that film became the
third highest money-making film in movie
history the Wow all right well done one
point one four billion dollars in ticket
sales second is Cameron's Titanic which
was 1.8 billion right that's a lot I
don't know they're gonna catch up to
know but number one is what though
number one is avatar avatar yeah 2.8
billion dollars odd Almighty
could you imagine James Cameron could
build the Death Star if he wanted to
he's got enough money to build the Death
Star when you're James counting you make
the Titanic they say congratulations you
have the biggest money-making film of
all time you gotta figure well that's
that's as good as it's gonna get for me
right yeah you don't think you're gonna
make another movie that's gonna best
that one and then become the new one
this dude he sees a mound he climbs it
sees another he goes after it like 1.89
he could have kicked back and just lived
off that the rest of his [ __ ] life
just not even the money but like the
[ __ ] credit like I've been living off
clerks for 20 years that's true yeah how
much money that made it didn't make
nearly this man of mine man
he said he's a doer that guy what an
achiever Rhys Ifans
it's good news this week he would not be
charged for pushing a female's body
guard security guard rather at comic-con
when he was there in San Diego most
recently he is the guy playing the
lizard he plays the lizard yes in the
new spider-man movie he was in Notting
Hill he was the friend
it was the wacky rule everybody
most people know him he's also in a
movie called pirate radio which I
thought was pretty funny on that show
awesome film
yeah the boat that rocked very good in
that he apparently pushed a female
bodyguard backstage and after he came
off the spider-man panel they she made a
citizen's arrest the security guard
top showed up and they decided not to
charge him so he's good to UM your
connection though you were on that path
I was the host of that panel yeah and he
was [ __ ] really allegedly if he has
his lawyers listening but they said show
the lizard footage and that introduced
him and bring him out and I didn't know
but this shit's going on backstage while
I'm waiting to introduce him and I
brought it out and I looked in the in
the wings and it was up a scuffle and
then he kind of was shoved on stage so
they let him go on but they said when he
comes offstage he's alright he's ours
you know and he came on and he was
hammered and I well first I was like
good on you sir because I appreciate a
man and go on stage with a good load on
but I was trying to involve him in the
conversation Andrew Garfield was there
and Emma Stone was there and the
director Marc Webb was there and I was
trying to involve him to the
conversation because it came on late and
I said so that footage looks amazing
Rhys and let me ask you how do you bring
humanity to a monster like the lizard
what was your thought process as an
actor I'm trying to you know bring
something out right and he just looked
at me all [ __ ] Busey and said we don't
bring humanity to monsters the monsters
bring you manatees do us and I'm looking
at I'm thinking what the [ __ ] am I gonna
do with that I said either he hates me
or he's drunk either way I'm not asking
him another [ __ ] question so I just
ignored him for the rest of the past
sounds profound it does for this act and
yet it means absolutely nothing
oh yeah yeah so that was my experience
with Rhys but I'm glad he's not being
arrested yeah good for him another
another guy I talked to a Comic Con this
year was Nicolas Cage I was hosting the
panel for a Ghost Rider - I know
look I had the same reaction but it
looks much better than Ghost Rider one
it's got the guys the guys that means
anything
the guys who did crank crank yeah
and Nicolas Cage says he's a psychic
Nicolas Cage claims he said when he was
9 years old
he had a vision and he knew that he'd be
playing The Ghost Rider someday hmm
couldn't that vision have warned him to
stay away from the first one and just
maybe skip over to tonight a bit more
helpful no it was unclear and [ __ ] well
Kevin I hate to tell you but it's the
end of our run here in Las Vegas Nevada
is it really yeah we're all done this is
us coming it's more Kevin coming up next
with Jason news we got more of that yeah
once we're done here we take a little
bit of 20-minute break you guys could
stretch grab drinks take a leak or
whatever then we come on back me and mr.
Jason Mewes to Jay and Silent Bob get
old for you into the wee hours of the
morning but this is Ben Aarthi we're
coming to the close and we always close
with one last funny funny bit but before
we ask soon
soon we will unsheath the [ __ ] but
before we do that big thank you from the
bottom of my heart probably from the
bottom of his tiny small black heart as
well
for coming out and being here for with
us this week thank you it was really
really cool thank you so much it's kind
of a dream come true to be able to play
Vegas yeah we talked it was weird well
like maybe the within the first five
episodes of us too and all I would
babble on it back it's mont castle we
talked we wimzie - bout like would it be
great to let go to Vegas with the show
like Oh that'll never happen here we our
dreams happen all the time so thank you
guys so much thank you out of that and
now without further ado there's a way we
end this show all the time man we have
to ask ourselves the immortal question
how the [ __ ] big is Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
oh we can't help but wonder how big is
genial nice in stock I love the New
Orleans feel of that it's nice if they
had his [ __ ] in New Orleans when Katrina
hit that never woulda been a flood they
could just put his [ __ ] up against the
levee and we would have been fine as the
loving never would have broke theorizing
that one could time-travel within his
own lifetime Liam Neeson's [ __ ] stepped
into the quantum leap accelerator and
vanished
he woke to find himself in the past
facing mirror images that were not his
own and driven by an unknown force to
change history for the better
his only guide on this journey is al an
observer from his own time who appears
in the form of a hologram that only Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] can see in here and so
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] finds himself leaping
from life to life striving to put right
what once was wrong and hoping that each
time his next leap will be the leap home
that was the longest longest one ever I
know I thought was well written for you
sci-fi fans Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
oh yes they did that last night that was
the first time it ever happened like
we've been doing Liam Neeson's [ __ ] for
a while well yeah that's weird though
we've been doing Liam Neeson's [ __ ] for
a while and I've been doing it for
longer than we've been doing this show
interesting but anyway last night when
we were doing it somebody said how big
is it or whatever and if [ __ ] had
captured our imagination so feel free to
play along it became an interactive bit
as of last night Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big that when he tried to steal
Christmas and all the who's and who
bills still gathered and sang anyway his
[ __ ] through grew three sizes larger
that day causing an avalanche and
killing everyone
I would not make it good special yeah
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that any
biography written about him could only
be a pop-up book Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big tourists visit his pants for some
exhilarating whitewater rafting wait I
have one I have one off the top of my
head
bring it Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
how big is it so big doesn't he pulled
the plug on its budget and Johnny Depp
has no role Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
when he pulls it out it flops bigger
than Jersey girl Oh [ __ ] prick Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big in the 70s it
was played by Lou Ferrigno I remember
that me too Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
once Liam got community service and
worked off his hours at a public
swimming pool as a diving board Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that tourists
are discouraged from dropping pennies
off the top of it they'll go right
through somebody's head Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big that after saving the
enterprise it Prest itself against the
plexiglass radiation shield and told Jim
Kirk I have been and always shall be
your friend since the Star Trek
conventions in town live long and
prosper Liam Neeson's [ __ ] Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big that his most recent
checkup LeAnn's neurologist broke the
news that he contracted genital Hogwarts
yes a large school for wizards had
sprung up on his shaft Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big
that even jon lovitz stops talking about
himself in its presence it's just my
personal favorite you gotta bring that
one back to the Lovett so we can hear it
no I think we should hear what happens
in Vegas stays well then Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big that when he goes
waterskiing he doesn't need a rope Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
Batman has an aerosol can of Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] repellent in the bat
copter Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that
when he pulls back his foreskin you hear
a beeping sound Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big that it must maintain multiple
citizenships as no one nation can
contain it
and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
that in the year 39 78 Charlton Heston
will be riding a horse along a beach and
spotted jutting out of the sand
oh my god you blew it up damn you on
ahead that's how it would babble on for
this week ladies the German
Smith I'm Ralph Garman Bible the [ __ ] on
Sin City and I thank you agus
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]